I have to ask you about this hacking
thing that you took nude pictures and I
guess who hacked you I don't even know I
was getting blackmailed by a dude I met
on match.com
no [ __ ] oh my god that's horrible
no [ __ ] [ __ ] you went out on the date
with this guy and I did never met the
[ __ ] I didn't realize getting
catfished oh I was getting catfished
I didn't [ __ ] realize do you know I
end up being a 10 year old end and a
baby oh [ __ ] I think it was some other
words somebody saw Leslie Jones is on
one of these things which means they
were posing as somebody else and I was
talking to this [ __ ] and
everything you know when you realize
you're being hacked right and you've
sent somebody these pictures who do you
call okay take us through it first first
what happened was whoever got it [ __ ]
put it up on on a site and so I called I
didn't even know Tim's he called my
phone oh my god TMZ karma four names
like yeah just TMZ so what you feel
about the new pictures I was like what
the end they put your phone number area
your passport now I was like wait I get
my phone or my passport I said and [ __ ]
you call the number so I hung up and I
called my publicist were you in a panic
because you're like pictures I was more
panic about them having my phone number
and my passport absolutely didn't
[ __ ] new packet give a [ __ ] about a
new pitch I've been trying to get them
out there anyway and you don't hear your
whole life you waiting to be famous you
get famous and now all I could think was
Laurens gonna [ __ ] kill me that's all
I kept thinking Lauren's gonna [ __ ]
kill me
so Lauren Roseman the publicist she's
[ __ ] the [ __ ] and she got it off in
20 minutes right how she's a badass
[ __ ] she got it off so then she the
first thing we do is go to the security
team then they take you to Homeland
Security
cuz Homeland Security was like oh he's
in another country we finna briefing to
get his ass if they could they get his
head if they
I would have been calm maybe because I
went to [ __ ] off
but then what end up happening was we
were working with the FBI did they want
you to do a sting where you would have
got another these guys yeah like I was
on the phone with anyone calm enough I
was not calm enough because the
[ __ ] got arrogant he was like I
was like all right so how much do you
want he was like yeah you need to send
25,000 to this then I was like it's
really [ __ ] up dude whether he was
like you know what let's make it 35,000
sounds like Oh
I was like you know what use a piece of
[ __ ] sitting there like I thought she
was an actress
you